Northwest proves she does Tick-Tock
better than everyone With a Little Help
from Ice spice it's really fun to see
Kim Kardashian and Kanye West's
nine-year-old daughter teamed up with
the musician creating not one not two
but three tick tocks together
[Music]
that's northie dancing with her friends
and I spice to the rapper's track in her
mood I don't know what's gonna top that
well then the crew acted out the lyrics
to Isis verse on boys a liar part two
but I don't sleep enough without you and
I can't eat enough without you if you
don't speak does that means
that you do that North shared this clip
lip syncing with ice spice alongside a
video rocking an orange curly wig just
like the rapper
and while the north the ice spice Tick
Tock collab is epic it doesn't come as a
surprise she's a big fan last month Kim
showed off her daughter's impressive art
skills on Instagram pencil sketches
North Drew of her famous fam and I spice
I love that and get this the musician
liked it so much she reposted it to her
own account then last week North gave
the rapper a shout out while listing off
her favorite artists
that's her thing and after their hang
North shared another drawing of ice to
Tick-Tock writing just met I spice
literally screaming she is so nice
[Music]
of course this is hardly the first time
North's dropped an epic collab last
month she teamed up with Mariah Carey's
daughter Monroe for this legendary
moment
I loved it to me that was epic in the
sense of where I always even said like
my daughter has the entertainment bug is
bitter the fact that they get to have
fun with each other like Tick Tock is
amazing
no wrong so wrong
[Music]